الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد
فقراءتنا موصوله
والتعليق موصول على كتاب رياض الصالحين من
كلام سيد المرسلين صلى الله عليه وسلم
في الباب الاول باب الاخلاص واحضار النيه
في الحديث السابع منه
رياض الصالحين
ابي هريره
يقول عن ابي هريره عبد الرحمن بن صخر
اي
الدوسي
رضي الله عنه ودوس
مدينه او قريه في اليمن
رضي الله عنه قال قال رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم
ان الله تعالى
لا ينظر الى اجسامكم
ولا الى صوركم
ولكن ينظر الى قلوبكم واعمالكم
رواه مسلم
ان الله تعالى
لا ينظر الى اجسامكم
ولا الى صوركم
يعني في الحكم
حينما يقضي الله سبحانه وتعالى ويحكم على
العبد دي
فانه تعالى لا ينظر الى الاجسام والى
الصور الظاهره
مجرده عن البواطن وعن النيات
وهذا هو الشاهد من ورود هذه الروايه في
هذا الباب
ان الله تعالى لا ينظر الى اجسامكم
ولا الى صوركم
لاحظوا كلمه ينظر ينظر
لم يقل لم يرى او لا يرى هو يرى كل شيء
سبحانه
ولكن النظر يختلف عن الرؤيه
لذلك
الله سبحانه وتعالى
يسمع كل شيء
لكن لا يستمع الى كل شيء سبحانه وتعالى
والله سبحانه وتعالى
يرى كل شيء
ولكن لا ينظر الى كل شيء سبحانه
لذلك من العقوبه يوم القيامه نسال الله
العافيه من العقوبه يوم القيامه ان الله
تعالى لا ينظر الى اقوامه
لا ينظر اليهم هل يراهم؟ يراهم ويرى كل
شيء لكن لا ينظر اليهم
ولا يزكيهم ولا يكلمهم
قال الله تعالى
لا ينظر اليهم
ولا يز ولا يكلمهم يوم القيامه ولا يزكيهم
ولهم عذاب اليم في عده عده ايات وفي
الحديث كذلك ثلاثه لا ينظر الله اليهم يوم
القيامه
ملك كذاب وشيخ زان وعائل مستكبر والروايات
كثيره في هذا الباب ففرق بين النظر
وبين الرؤيه وفرق بين الاستماع
والسماع
يقول هنا ان الله تعالى لا ينظر
الى اجسامكم
ولا الى صوركم
ولكن ينظر
الى قلوبكم
الى النيه الى
الاعتبار الى النيه والى ايه عمل القلب
وقول القلب واعمالكم
هذه الزياده
جاءت في الروايه الاخرى عند الامام مسلم
وهي الروايه التي ذكرها واختارها النووي
هنا لماذا؟ لان الشطر الاول اشتهر على
السن الناس لكن الناس
لا يذكرون هذه الزياده فيجعلون الروايه
حجه لهم في زعمهم على عملهم الفاسد
فيقولون نعم هذا عمل فاسد يصدر مني لكن
الله يعلم ما في قلبي وكان القلب الصالح
يصدر منه الفساد في العمل هذا كلام لا يدل
عليه لا عقل ولا عاده ولا شرع ولا كتاب
ولا سنه ولكن
العمل الصالح يصدر من النيه الصالحه
والعمل الفاسد يصدر من النيه الفاسده
لذلك جاءت هذه الروايه
مرتين في كتاب الامام مسلم ال ال اللفظ
الاول ان الله تعالى لا ينظر الى اجسامكم
ولا الى صوركم ولكن ينظر الى قلوبكم الى
هنا
ثم في المره الثانيه ان الله تعالى لا
ينظر الى اجسامكم ولا الى صوركم ولكن ينظر
الى قلوب قلوبكم واعمالكم
فهذا بمعنى هذا
لان ال القلب هو الامر للجوارح كالملك هو
الامر للجنود
فالعمل الصالح يصدر عن القلب الصالح
والعمل الفاسد والفساد يصدر عن قلب فاسد
لذلك لا تعتبر النيه فيما ما هو لا يحتمل
التاويل ما معنى هذا الكلام لا تعتبر
النيه في ما لا يحتمل التاويل سنذكره ان
شاء الله
ابي هريره رضي الله عنه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏B to outesaningudg
rather look to yours and
looking different seeing
hearing is different listening
الله سبحانه hears everyone and
everything but he does not listen to
everyone and everything
الله سبحانه وتالى
and
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏will look
people
will them will not look at them and will
not and will not listen to them this
narration is commonly misunderst indeed
Allah does not look at your b nor your
outward images meaning in judgment when
he judges you rather he looks to
‏nared with the first rather he looks at
your hearts without the action and so
many people misunderstand this narration
they think that this narration is excuse
oridence
that bad deeds can be justified with
good intention and that
‏paradoxical
deeds come from
and bad come from bad intention
as forakes
or as for flukes
or random events sure but even a good
deed that is done with bad intentions is
judged as a what a bad deed
يفتح الشيطان على الانسان 99
بابا من الخير ليفتح عليه بابا واحدا من
الشر
الشيطان
of him
and
this heread
الشافعي رحمه الله
الرساله
first not
اصول الفقهران
رحمه
‏intentions because this is intentions
is oftenund
what does he mention he mentions
that
intentions are only taken into account
with regards to actions
that are ambiguous that's the principle
listen to the statement he say
intentions are only taken
‏in particular
intention is only taken into account
when the action is ambiguous
meaning it could be good it could be bad
but based on the intention judge if this
is good or bad that's the time when
intention is taken into account
however
intention is not taken
‏isically
what is example of this
for instancequ
the act ‏could
make
حاضي
الله عنه
مكه
مشركين
صلى الله عليه وسلم
علي بن ابي طالب other
was صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما حملك على هذا يا حاطب
‏compion
was
et and asked him why you
because this is not categorically
it could be for a reason it could be for
aigious reason and so intention here
‏ruling.
However, if the action itself is
unambus, the action itself is
is explicit and can only be interpreted
in one way.
عليه
الله
تبوك
الله سبحانه وتعالى
عبد الله بنما
كنا نخوض ونلعب
كفر
كفر الله
invalid by doing so why because this
good intention or innocent intention
does not what does not justify a
categorically bad act an act that is
categorically bad there is no valid
excuse for it ever there is no that
pushes for it
الشافعي يقول النيات
انما تعتبر
فيما لا يحتم فيما يحتمله
التاويل في الاعمال
النيات تعتبر
انما تعتبر فيما يحتمل التاويل
فيما يحتمل التاويل من الاعمال ولكن النيه
لا تعتبر
في ما لا يحتمل التاويل موسى عليه
‏was
in
to desecrate
he was very angry therefore his
intentions taken into consideration
this is
how this principle is to be understood a
person is never to understand that I can
do bad things and then I can claim that
I had good intentions.
‏things
in this